Wonderland is a new show by MTV that's
really bringing music back I get that
opportunity to perform songs live
wonderland is live MTV Music Show but as
important does that wonderland a massive
live event Dominical downtown LA
wonderland is special because we go from
the television broadcast straight into
the Facebook live broadcast seamlessly
into the MTV snapchat into the Instagram
I'll be a camera that it's probably
stuff for TV broadcast there'll be
another camera that it's feeding into a
digital stream that goes up somewhere
else there'll be someone jumping in with
a phone to get Paul the snapchat story
so everything is going to be together
we're actually what some people may
consider the slash generation which
means we're all into like a lot of
different things
I think Wonderland is that we're
everywhere young people our work
everywhere that we would be and it's
just like taking your music with you in
your pocket people historically are used
to having very clear-cut ideas of what
kind of music people are making but I am
a multi-faceted artist so I'm excited to
see that become more accepted in the
future each of our performance spaces we
have two or three fixed cameras and then
we have two handheld cameras become any
capture those reporters for the follow
stream we have a camera that has full
access across the site just roads around
kind of all other
so place ruin is a old warehouse complex
in the middle of downtown LA and it's
taking it in a really good way the
actually opposite of a traditional city
new studio and we've come in and just
getting that kind of production design
like that
we just kept a lot of the aesthetics the
raw building structure it's really
grungy and feels to be from LA I want
people to take away from this experience
just a general appreciation for music
and live moving again I think it's been
a while since we've made it as important
as it really is and this is just one
step in that direction which is really
exciting